hey youtubers is Charlie avatar wisdom
is a thing of the past
no wait no book three just premiered the
first three episodes just premiered
back-to-back this video is just gonna be
a review the first two and then tomorrow
instead of doing a Q&A video I'm gonna
do a review of that third episode hello
to all the new people just finding me
for the first time I'm gonna be doing
weekly core videos and I'm also doing a
weekly giveaway all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video
don't worry I'll explain again how it's
all gonna work at the end of this video
so we've got a whole lot of stuff to
talk about and what I'm gonna do since
I'm reviewing two episodes in this video
is I'm gonna do my top 10 moments then
I'll do my review and then I'll explain
the giveaway again Oh careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but here we go number 10 core saw me
driving lessons I know how the course
ami shippers from books one and two
flipped a little whenever they realized
how close Cornus ami were gonna be in
book 3 the driving lesson spells out
their dynamic fairly perfectly I think
they both like to poke fun at each other
and make jokes but neither one is you
know really upset about the other one
hooking up with Ma Co whenever they were
going out with them respectively
in that situation I think mako's more
the person to blame anyway I feel like
if you did a Korra power rankings list
ma Co would have just shot straight to
the bottom in the first few moments of
the first episode it's not super clear
what his character arc is gonna be in
book 3 but I already feel pretty bad for
him I will enjoy Koren Asami torturing
him a little bit what are friends for if
not for embarrassing you every chance
they get so something really important
is happening between the two of them and
Korra literally called it out she's
never had like a really close girlfriend
that she could confide in before I think
that's pretty depressing but I'm really
glad the show's turning it around
based on the first couple of episodes it
seems like Asami is gonna be spending
the most amount of time with Korra on
screen like most of course scenes will
also involve Asami I'm really glad that
whenever Koren Asami started bonding
together they didn't just start talking
about other boys they started talking
about their own interest and they
started problem-solving like scooby-doo
style I feel like a lot of shows that
skew towards younger audiences have
females spend way too much time talking
about the male characters and not enough
about their own interests but I think
one of the best things about Legend of
Korra is is that it portrays a very
positive female perspective but that's
nothing to I think everybody understands
that for instance it was a Siamese idea
to use the dark spirit calming technique
to get rid of the vines
it didn't require a male character
suggesting that to her before she
figured it out
number nine Tenzin talks to Aang statue
this was just so heartwarming Tenzin
speaking to the spirit of a while
looking at his statue in the bay it's
unclear what happened to course past
lives and the spirits of the former
avatars but you're really not thinking
about that in this moment whenever he
was talking to the statue I instantly
thought of that moment when Aang
realized that the entire air nation had
been murdered it was such a
heartbreaking scene and I'm really glad
that they're paying that off now with
this new plot it's really unclear why
harmonic convergence caused people to
manifest airbending and no other bending
forms but I think that's gonna be
something that it'll take all season for
us to learn for now though I just think
it's so awesome that they paid off like
a plot point that served as the basis
for the entire last airbender series
number eight look at this effing
Airbender hipster this is one of those
scenes that just makes you want to shoot
this little kid or maybe laugh out loud
not at the same time we're not psychos
here I feel like this is Mike and Bryan
in the writers just making fun of
20-somethings in general or maybe it's
them making fun of themselves for being
that 20-something kid that lived in
their parents house way too long
I don't know a lot about Mike and Bryan
pre avatar last airbender or the writers
for that matter the whole idea people
not wanting to become part of the air
nation was kind of infuriating and this
hipster kid was just the worst of it I
feel like he was like the comedic offset
for the farmer who also didn't want to
go but had like a much more legit reason
number seven Tenzin is the world's worst
salesman this is one of the most
difficult ashes in all of the new
episodes you get to be a vegetarian you
get tattoos all over your body you get
to give away all your possessions you
get these amazing robes the one pitch
that I did think was really good was
that you get to have a giant air bison
as a best friend I mean who would not
want a giant bison as a best friend you
could name it Appa Junior all the
refusal just reminded me of Yoda's quote
from Empire Strikes Back too old to
begin the training it's just a metaphor
for the idea that once you become an
adult you become so close-minded about
the idea of a new reality which is
exactly what Sahir said to the White
Lotus guards whenever he escaped it just
makes me feel like Korra is going to
have to open up the world to the idea of
a new reality like get used to all the
new spirits and the way things are
number six team avatar circus
performance this really reminded me of
that play from last airbender you know
in that episode the play was based very
literally on The Adventures of team
avatar and on Korra I think the play was
a little closer approximation of her
battle with them on but watching this
made me realize we need more moustache
Bolin more shirtless Tenzin which was
kind of weird given that I usually think
of JK Simmons whenever Tenzin talks and
just more theatricality in general I
just love how Bolin is still trying to
ride on the coattails of all his nuktuk
stuff like his future is very clearly in
the performing arts you know not in some
sort of like pro-bending stuff so
whenever all their big adventures are
over and they gonna go their separate
ways like the original team avatar did
to start families i really hope that
bolin turns into the steven spielberg of
the Avatar world number 5 meet Kai new
member of team avatar it's a little
surreal thinking about all the people as
airbenders whenever they're dressed like
earthbenders less Airbender treated the
colors in the bending Styles a little
more rigidly but the whole idea is that
they're searching for these new
airbenders inside the earth Kingdom so
of course everyone is dressed in green
as of right now kya is a very fun
character but I don't think he's gonna
be one of my new favorites
you know just based on that all the
people we've met so far he feels a
little less compelling than some of the
evil benders I think technically they're
not even really that evil but just to
distinguish them for now I'm gonna call
them that whenever we met Toph for the
first time she lied about her past but
that was really just to avoid being
judged for being so wealthy I don't
think that's the case with Kai but I'm
interested to see if his backstory has
something that relates to the main story
of course it's totally possible that
it's something that's not really meant
to be paid off like he's just an orphan
and that's it there's nothing more
complicated than that but if he lied
about the gold he could have lied about
his parents being killed by Raiders so
we need more information about him
before I passed judgment as for the
Jinora shipping that's going to be
happening with you know him and her this
season I think it's interesting but it's
not gonna be as fun as the korrasami
stuff so I'm not gonna invest a whole
lot of Jif energy into Jinora and Kai
number for the Republic City spirit
right at the beginning whatever of
course first dealing with the vines the
spirit who was totally awesome
completely says that the premise of the
season Tenzin did it too and there will
probably several other characters like
Sahir
who also call out we know what the big
arc of book 3 is
there is no difference between the
spirits and the people we are the same
the avatar of all people should know
that the idea being that this is gonna
be something that's gonna cook inside
Cora's brain until eventually you know
at the climax of the season it's gonna
turn into something actionable usually
when things like this happen
you know first she learns a new lesson
like achieving true inner peace in book
one then she's able to do something with
it you know in that case it was
airbending in book three this could mean
a lot of different things done a lot of
different levels but mostly I think it's
just gonna translate to people getting
used to living with spirits and visually
I think they're just gonna call that out
as the vines will stop destroying the
city you know once she's able to
complete that plan quick sidenote - we
haven't seen a lot of them yet but there
will be tons of really cool looking
spirits floating all over the world
we've seen a couple of them in the
trailer but eventually as the episodes
get on we will meet some other big
spirits number three the twins are back
it took a few episodes last year for me
to get used to him it wasn't really till
Eska flipped out and chased after bolin
- korra that i started loving her
Aubrey Plaza is so appropriate for that
character I've seen her in some shows
and movies where she doesn't play that
type of flat emotionless person but most
of all I just picture April from Parks
and Rec I think it's so funny that
they're ruling the Northern Water Tribe
I think that's just because the position
is hereditary although avatar doesn't
completely explain that in really great
detail did anyone else think they heard
Dez Aneta call Zuko uncle Zuko
the room I was watching the episode in
was really loud so I wasn't sure but I
just loved the idea that they would do
that I think it's true - because Zuko
said that he built that special
underground prison for Ming law with
unalaq which means he would have had to
visit the Northern Water Tribe a long
time ago I also noticed in the trailers
that the twins were fighting against
these evil benders so maybe we'll
eventually see like a Bolin
ESCA reunion by the end of the season
that would be funny and very awkward
number two is a hero escapes I love that
this was right as Tenzin gave that you
know really hopeful speech about finding
new airbenders don'tdon't on cue scary
music it didn't say it right away but
Zaheer is the leader of the evil bending
team and he was not an airbender until
harmonic convergence his quote about
guru Mahima was a nice callback to guru
Pathik
but mostly he was just doing what Tenzin
was doing you know kind of heralding the
idea of change you know change is coming
and it's not
gonna be something that everyone's gonna
like it's unclear why he wants to kill
the avatar and the order the White Lotus
but it's not just another version of the
plan that una vaatu had you know helping
spirits dominate the physical realm I'm
hoping the next couple of episodes spell
out their thesis a little bit better so
I'll be talking about episode 3 in my
video tomorrow mostly but there was
something Korra learned in that episode
you know the earth Queen episode that
she was fighting for the wrong person
you know in that case it was the earth
Queen versus the people but I'm
wondering if this evil bending team is
gonna do the same thing with her feel
like you are fighting for the wrong
cause I guess that would be another
version of what unavaatu was doing you
know getting her to help the spirits at
the expense of helping people but it's
still a little early to tell and we
don't quite know exactly how their plan
is going to work out or how they want it
to work out who else love those magneto
prisons they were all kept in - I'm
assuming the Zuko help built them all
with the help of you know leaders in
each of the nations that they were kept
in and my number one moment Lord Zuko
returns why he waited till after
harmonic convergence to make an
appearance you know I have no idea we're
just happy he finally came to the party
of all the classic avatar characters
he's definitely one of my favorite and
even though dante basco isn't voicing
him i still think he's gonna be awesome
I think eventually he's going to explain
what his real mission has been this past
couple of years like what he was doing
during Korra books wanted to and maybe
that might help us figure out where Toph
is I saw a little bit of younger Zuko's
temper whenever he found that
waterbender had been freed they were in
the Fire Nation so it makes sense that
that's where he would appear first even
though at that point see here had
already freed two of the people I will
say I had a moment of pure joy whenever
Zuko was riding down the elevator to
sparky-sparky boom girls cell and they
bonded with the twins over trying to
kill the avatar or different avatars but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what was your favorite
moment from these first couple of
episodes I will be talking about that
earth Queen episode in the video
tomorrow but overall I thought these
episodes were great you know I gave them
a solid b-plus I think it was definitely
worth the wait and I think they did a
really good job of setting up you know
who the new characters are and what it
is that they're trying to do team avatar
will try and find and help all the new
airbenders rebuild the air nation and
contains the here steam and Zaheer
clearly has a progression of trying to
kill the avatar and the White Lotus I do
that it's gonna be a big challenge for
them to tie in lin beifong's story to
this master plot by the end of the
season and they haven't even set up the
beifong story yet she hasn't really
ended the story yet one of the big
problems with having so many plots is
that they all have to connect by the end
of the season all little side stories
you don't have to inform this main story
in book two I felt like there were a few
things that did not get paid off like
Forex story for instance I feel like he
ultimately wasn't necessary like he was
just created to give mokou Bolin and
Asami something to do it didn't
necessarily have an impact on harmonic
convergence or the fight against you
know vaatu the thing that I'm really
liking about book 3 so far based on
these first couple of episodes is that I
definitely have a pretty solid idea of
how they're all going to come together
by the end of the season like they've
been set up in such a way that it's
pretty clear you know where they're
gonna intersect by the end of the year
aura will have to educate the earth
Queen on treating her people better
she'll have to help the people in
Republic City learned to live with
spirits and she'll have to make peace
with Zaheer's team so like I said my
episode 3 of you is gonna post tomorrow
that's the earth Queen episode be sure
to subscribe to get it
and for the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is leave a comment on this
video and be a subscriber it's the same
deal with tomorrow's video too but in
this video because it was based on two
episodes I'm gonna give away two gift
cards and then tomorrow I'll just be one
gift card right now click here to get
that episode 3 video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and
click here to learn about my top 5
characters that I'm looking forward to
in book 3 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]